[Music]
after it put together this talk I
realized that the talk was probably more
appropriately titled changing the
paradigm on metric management so who
here does any sort of metric definition
management building dashboards anything
like that raise your hand yeah that's a
lot of what we do isn't it
thanks for a second about all the steps
that you go through when you're doing
that I'm giving you a little bit of time
good and it's anything like where we
started at Airbnb it's probably a lot of
steps this is what the workflow for
metric management looked like an Airbnb
last year it's nine steps it involves
first creating a table scheduling a job
baffling that table so you have
historical data adding it to your a be
testing platform adding it to our
dashboarding top platform actually
building that dashboard adding a tour
normally detection platform telling all
your consumers to update their queries
and where where they can find it and
finally ongoing work to monitor stuff
and fix it if it breaks
if you have to do all of this is there
time to do anything else
I was a data scientist I actually
started an Airbnb as a data scientist on
our growth team and this is what I did
all the time and it drove me nuts
so I actually switched teams and roles
to fix this problem
hi everyone I'm Lauren I am a product
manager on our data platform team at
Airbnb I like I said I was previously a
data scientist I Airbnb our mission is
to make sure that anyone can belong
anywhere and one of the main ways that
we do that is helping hosts I connect
with travelers who are looking for
places to stay
this here is a picture one of my
favorite listings that I stayed at it's
near Salinas and Monterey my hosts
included two very friendly llamas - very
nice sheep and those very thoughtful
woman named Susan who literally messed
nothing it was a great experience highly
recommended and I'm here today to tell
you that you can change the paradigm on
that metric management workflow that I
just showed you so today at Airbnb this
is what our workflow looks like it's two
steps it takes about 10 - the time as
that previous workflow that I showed and
actually that second step of creating
dashboards we send me automated net so
that's that also is
so today I'm going to walk you through
how we did that starting with where we
started at Airbnb last year why we
decided that for us dimension should be
front and center in our metrics platform
and why if you're tackling this problem
at your company you might consider that
too and finally why we chose to
prioritize features for our metric
producers our metric creators very early
on and why you might want to do that too
so you can make sure that this is
actually adopted and used by your name a
scientist at your company so where do we
start like many companies we had a
plethora of tools for managing metrics
and accessing metrics starting on the
right here with air flow which we've
heard a ton about in the last day and a
half a very popular job scheduler that
came out of Airbnb we used super set for
our dashboarding purposes and four
metric exploration there was a great
talk by max de jamón last year at this
conference if you want to look that up
you have an anomaly detection platform
so that if there is something wrong with
your metrics you get alerted or if
there's a substantial change in your
metrics you get alerted we have an a/b
testing platform and we have a tool
called data portal which also has talks
available in the internet if you want to
learn more about it this is a tool that
allows anyone across the company to
search for data and find what they need
this is all built on top of a strong
open source based compute environment in
particular we use hive which is a
distributed sequel engine presto which
is a faster distributed sequel engine
and druid which there was also talked
about last year so you can look that up
druid is a datastore that actually does
all the hard computational work when you
load the data in so first slice and dice
analytics you get really fast
I returns on your queries and we
leverage that a lot in our metrics
framework in addition to the workflow
pain points that we talked about earlier
there were also pain points with
consuming metrics despite that plethora
of applications I first of all metrics
couldn't be reused across these
different platforms the data scientists
had to individually onboard them via
config to every single one of those
systems and this isn't just a pain point
actually this is a real problem for the
business because it results in
discrepancies in the data between these
tools and that degrades the trust in the
data and can actually lead to bad
decisions and we saw it leading to bad
decisions across the company
additionally metrics were hard to find
despite the fact that we have data
portal which is an amazing tool for
finding data entities that exist at the
company the best that you could do was
find a metric or or find a table or a
dashboard I you didn't know how to a
granade that the data from that table if
you weren't previously exposed to it a
lot of things lack documentation and
finally after you found that table if
you didn't know sequel you're screwed um
and I also and then you had to have a
data data scientist prepare a dashboard
for you and we actually surveyed people
across the company about whether they
had access to the data that they needed
to make good business decisions and one
of the top complaints was actually lack
of access to data scientists this is the
kind of work data scientists like to do
it's they call it fetch work and Airbnb
so we knew that we had a real problem we
needed to solve between these pain
points with accessing metrics and making
decisions based on them and the workflow
stuff that we talked about earlier this
is this was causing real problems in the
so we built a global metrics framework
it sits on top of all the tools that we
talked about before unites them together
and allows for high leverage in the
business by reducing reducing redundancy
which sounds redundant on its own um and
today I'm going to tell you some lessons
that we learned as we built this so what
is global metrics I we defined global
metrics as the concept that you should
define your metric in one place one
place only that it should be available
in all the applications where you need
it and that there is enough
documentation of metadata associated
with those metrics that when you access
them you know what to do with it
and if you have a question about it you
know who to ask so as we started to
build this we had a question about
whether we could reuse existing
infrastructure was a ML feature
repository built by our ml and Fred team
and we thought that maybe these these
are similar things conceptually you know
a metric and a feature are are not that
different from each other you use things
that could be metrics to describe your
business as inputs to models or to as
the output of or the thing that you're
training on frequently um so and naively
on a high level of these look the same
you need to have a conflict layer to
store that logic and the metadata
associated with your metric or feature
you need to have a computer that
calculates it and then you need to serve
it to all of your metric consuming
applications or feature consuming
applications in the case of a male
models these consuming applications are
models such as our pricing model and our
fraud model
and in the case of metrics these are the
applications that we talked about before
but after sitting down with our ml team
and arguing about it for approximately
half a day we've discovered that they're
pretty different actually that there are
some different requirements of these
frameworks for metrics in particular I
you want to leverage as much information
as possible in order to understand user
behavior and sometimes that can include
future information that you don't have
at the time that that that the event
you're basing that metric on occurred
for example a lot of our users are
logged out when they access Airbnb and
we want to know if they're going to
convert to bookings so we want to go
back to the beginning and convert to say
that that log dot user was actually this
person who made this booking five days
later additionally our metrics are
needed entirely offline there's really
no online use case for a metric that
leads to different compute requirements
and finally there are a lot of types of
a lot of types of metrics who wanted to
support so in addition to the fact that
like standard metrics most of them you
just sum over like the number of times a
user clicked on something or at Airbnb
the number of times they booked a
listing I there are also the idea of
conversion metrics so how did how long
did it take for that new listing to get
its first booking we also frequently use
ratio metrics across the company I where
the numerator and denominator could be
from entirely different data sources on
the other hand ml features had their own
requirements so unlike where we wanted
to know as much information about our
metric as possible for ml you have a
very strict requirement to prevent data
leakage you do not want that future
information polluting your model and
because that can degrade the output and
if your model is in production you
experience in addition ml features need
to be available both online and offline
leads to a need for variable types of
compute and finally they have their own
complex types of calculations that they
need to support so between all of these
things we decided that they are
fundamentally different problems that
need fundamentally different
infrastructure to solve the basics are
similar but the details are different
and the things that are powerful about
these frameworks are really those
details it's we we actually are
beginning to come back around to revisit
this decision now that the global
metrics framework is built and up and
running we realize that this can
actually be an upstream input data
source for our ml models and we're
beginning to think about how that
integration might work so one of the
things that turned out to be pretty
different between our ml feature
requirements and our metric requirements
was the requirement for how they handled
dimensions so it Airbnb turns out
dimensions are really important and
there are a few reasons and I think that
they're going to be extensible to a lot
of other companies so first of all a lot
of the metrics we track across the
company are actually just dimensional
cuts of other metrics second a lot of
our metrics have hundreds of dimensions
that people might care to cut them by
and third we strongly believe in D
normalization for analytics purposes so
you might ask why do you believe so
strongly in de normalization for
analytics and it's because it makes it
so much faster also makes your data much
more reliable because if you have a
normalized data model like what is shown
at the top here every time you access
that data you need to remember how those
joins happen and you need to pay for the
cost of compute right then so it takes
much longer to execute that query and
get your
result back and frequently you just want
to know what God answer is but if you
have a to normalize model like what's
shown at the bottom the date is all
there it's easy to do your group eyes
and filters and it's especially much
easier for less technical folks like our
product managers who are frequently
accessing these datas to make this data
to make decisions
additionally like I said for this
framework we decided to leverage druid
and druid doesn't let you do joins so it
was a fundamental limitation we had to
normalize all of our data and the reason
that druid doesn't let you do joins is
because when the data is loaded in its
aggregated so here's some example dummy
data that you might see in droid I'm you
might notice there the timestamp column
some dimension columns and a metric
column but what's missing is an ID and
that's because you don't get that
performance if you load in atomic data
you would have to still pay that compute
cost at the time of querying it
so like I said another reason that we
had needed to handle this dimension
question was because a lot of our
metrics at Airbnb are actually just
dimensional cuts of other metrics for
example as a company we look at bookings
but the growth team looks at first-time
bookings our China team looks at
bookings in China and our Airbnb for
work team wants to know about how many
business trip bookings there were and
apologize so these are these are really
just dimensional cuts of bookings
additionally these are the metrics they
track but the power comes in when
they're able to do ad hoc exploratory
analysis cutting by any arbitrary
dimension so people don't just want to
know bookings in China today they might
want to know bookings in China from
North America by ho status tomorrow they
want to know might want to know bookings
in China by platform our arbitrary
dimensional cuts in order to understand
what's happening in our business so in
order to solve this problem we turn to a
familiar concept in data warehousing
that you are many of you are probably
familiar with we look to star schema and
in a star schema it's centered around
fact tables which are tables of atomic
events basically where your metrics live
and these join to dimension tables on
foreign keys to bring in that additional
context for our global metrics use case
we renamed these things a little bit our
fact tables became metric sources our
dimension tables became dimension
sources and we renamed the foreign key
subjects part of the reason we renamed
these things was for consistency with
our other internal tools for example
subject is a term that was already used
in our a/b testing platform but another
reason that we renamed them is because
in our framework these aren't tables
these are actually gamma based configs
so
these are this is the layer that our
data scientists interact with this is
where they're going to be doing all
their work from now moving forward at
least metric management work um so let's
take a look at a sample metric source
config for example the config where we
define our key metric bookings and
you'll notice that this config contains
two metrics bookings and the number of
nights there were in each booking there
are three subjects associated with it
listing the host the listing that
they're staying at the host who has that
listing and the guest who's actually
going to stay there and then the data
scientist has specified three dimensions
that they want to be able to cut these
metrics by and in our framework this is
all the data scientist has to do to
bring in that metric because what the
framework does is it looks for where
those metrics are defined in a dimension
source configs and automatically does
that join on the right subject this
standard this way of defining
dimensional joins provides a huge
benefit it introduces rigor and make
sure that every time a dimensions use
it's used exactly the same way and the
way it's supposed to it provides
consistency and it's a whole lot less
work than specifying not join yourself
so the next problem that we had to
tackle was that some of our metrics in
particular bookings literally has
hundreds of dimensions across the
company that people want to cut it by
and these dimensions are different
different teams care about different
subsets of these dimensions and some of
them might be really expensive
for example our host team wants to be
able to cut their metrics by the
lifetime value of the listing that was
booked this dimension is the output of a
machine learning model so itself it
takes a long time to compute and it
lands later in the day so if we waited
for this dimension and all the other
dimensions
that we needed to show up in order to
land bookings data every day that would
be a big problem for a company because
every team in the company would have to
wait until like after work hours in
order to understand the number of
bookings that happened yesterday so to
solve this we introduced a concept
called dimension sets and these
dimension sets give our data scientists
control over their own assaleh z-- for
their their section of that metric r and
the dimensions associated with it so
instead of just specifying a list of
dimensions in our config we now have a
dimension set section the China team can
define their own dimensions shown here
in purple ish and the host team can
define their set of dimensions shown
here in yellow and we automatically
create two different tables one table
for each dimension set and the metrics
are in both of those tables and if a new
team needs to be able to cut their
metric by a different set of dimensions
they can just add new dimension a new
dimension set to this config just a
couple lines of not even code a couple
lines of Yahoo config and will
automatically create another table for
them and load this table and to Druid so
that it's there for super fast slice and
dice analytics so we've actually started
to think about our metrics framework as
a de normalization machine this is where
this is why it has become so powerful in
order to be able to make quick decisions
and understand what's what's happening
in our business because now every team
is empowered to cut I to be able to look
at the metrics they care about cut by
whatever dimensions they want they can
produce these tables in by just writing
a couple of lines in a config and within
a day the data is there populated
backfilled ready for them to use so
we started with a very complicated nine
step workflow I by just adding in the
basic functionality that we talked about
now on like how we oughta generate
tables from these convicts we've
eliminated three steps admittedly we
added one more writing the convicts but
the next thing that we did was we hooked
up all these tables that were
auto-generating and leveraged the
metadata that we capture in those con
figs which I stripped out in our
examples for simplicity to our metric
consuming apps so we were able to right
off the bat eliminate three more steps
and now we're down to four so next I'm
going to tell you about how how and why
we prioritize some what you might call
special features for metric producers
before we officially launched this I and
why this was really important for
adoption for us and in the process maybe
we can eliminate a couple more of these
steps so we have a saying at Airbnb love
drives growth not the other way around
that applies to our internal tools as
well so to that end we built a whole
bunch of features that basically gave
free stuff to our data scientists first
we automatically detect when you add a
new metric into one of these configs
when you change the logic that
calculates those metrics when you add a
new dimension or when you change the
logic that calculates those dimensions
and we automatically do that backfill
for you I've we heard today a little bit
of talked about earlier during the
keynote of about data versioning and
model versioning this is our first
attempt to have that concept at Airbnb I
basically half the configs
to see if there was a change we store
that hash as a alongside the data so
that we can know which date
which data is I which data goes with
which version of these convicts second
we added self-healing properties to the
pipeline so pipelines don't always run
there are issues when there's an issue
in our compute environment or an
upstream table gets delayed the data
might not land for a couple days data
scientists hate going into air flow and
checking off boxes data engineers hate
that - like nobody likes doing that so
every time the pipeline runs it checks
to see if what data has been computed if
there's a gap in the data that's been
computed it automatically fills that in
and third we since we had so much
metadata in these configs
about white metrics are being created
and what their purpose was we were able
to write a script that auto-generate
supersets dashboards so this is an
integrated into the pipeline that's
still a sort of one-off task but it now
takes a data scientist about two minutes
to build a dashboard whereas if you were
going to point and click and super set
it could take you an afternoon so these
additional bonus features let us
eliminate two more steps and last step -
just a couple of minutes so as a
reminder this is where we started it was
tedious complicated and if you were a
leak even simple Tait changes took about
two weeks to execute this is where we
are today it's - really one and a half
steps and it takes less than two days
and we really have driven love so by one
of our earliest adopters we partnered
very closely with data scientists as we
started building this out in order to
make sure we were building exactly the
right things one of our data scientists
said it has dramatically reduced their
time to insight even before they had all
these like nice bonus features another
data scientist was just blown away by
all the data management features and
like shouting from the rooftops about
how trivial this is now and my favorite
quote literally got this one so at the
time of official launch which was
actually just last week we already had
over 20 teams who had contributed
metrics over 350 metrics on the platform
not an even including all the dimensions
that I just talked about and we have
less technical folks like folks from
Finance value on the door asking how
they can do it learning it so they can
so they can contribute and of course we
added adoption metrics as a metric into
our framework and this is just a little
gift to show you how speedy it is to
interact with these metrics and supers
that so just breaking down a like total
number of objects in our framework by
the type of object it is whether it's an
events or symmetric or dimension so I
just walked you through how we changed
that paradigm at Airbnb and some lessons
that we learned along the way that I
hope maybe if you're tackling these
problems you can apply at your companies
and why or early on it's really
important to prioritize features that
data scientists that metric producers
love so that they can so that loads up
metrics onto your platform
the next thing that we're working on is
building out more metrics for building
up more features for our metric
consumers because now we have a hundred
or 350 metrics plus on the platform we
need to help people find them so we are
doing integrations with superset in
order to surface that metadata help
people know what they're what they're
looking at when they and right where
they interact and superset we're
integrating with the tool data portal
that I told you about earlier so that
people can search for a metric by name
in data portal and easily find it be
able to do deep dives from there and
finally we're going to add a metric
certification process so people can feel
really confident when they find those
much
that this is this is a quality thing the
other thing we're starting to think
about is open sourcing this I so you
might have noticed that the we built
this on top of a bunch of really great
open-source tools two of which came out
of Airbnb and the spring weren't
actually really nicely tie is airflow
and super set together and we're
building a whole bunch of additional
functionality into super set in order to
support this so we're starting to think
about how we might go about open
sourcing this if you're interested in
talking about this or partnering on open
source we would love to talk to you
about it
I come to office hours chat with us if
you have any other questions about this
framework how we built it I've come to
office hours happy to take them now you
can also hit me up on Twitter LinkedIn
or email and I also just want to shout
out to Amit who is the engineer who did
most the work he's here today and he can
also answer your questions so thanks so
much and I'm happy to start taking any
now if we have time
questions anyone so in the metric
definition you know where you have
dimension set I'm like where any team
can add that so how you or duplicate
like you know so the possible that you
know many different teams are you know
partitioning by the same dimensions yeah
so I think your question is about how do
we make sure that people aren't
duplicating stuff so this is a big worry
we have and right now the process is I
personally review every single metric
that gets added obviously that doesn't
scale so what we're starting to do is
we're starting to train a point person
or to point people from each data
science team in order to look for the
things that I've been looking for to
make sure that there isn't duplication
to make sure that they're leveraging the
dimensions in the right way because we
we've also we need to shift the mindset
of our data scientists from doing those
joins themselves and so we're going to
have point people on each team who will
review stuff and also run trainings for
their team so that they know how to use
it most effectively
so there are certain dimensions you know
that have can have high cardinality you
know how you know because in that case
you know the job becomes super expensive
you know how we can like avoid it like
where is the threshold for that yeah so
this is also a huge concern this is
actually the second reason we came up
with the concept of dimension sets
because you lose all of the goodness of
Druid when you have high cardinality
dimensions and all of a sudden you have
like super high latency queries and
that's no fun so I what we encourage
people to do is to separate out those
super high cardinality dimensions into
their own dimension sets so that I
they're still available but sort of in
there like isolated own world and they
don't impact all the other things
thanks for an awesome presentation my
question is if I'm an application
developer and I need to get access to
those metrics do you publish it anywhere
or is so we right now we publish the
data in tables in hive
it's ugly for people to query ad-hoc so
we put some like nice views on top of it
to flatten out and make it look like
what data scientists want and we are
loading the data into druid i the next
step is to I had like packaged our
config parser and I together and make an
API that is actually accessible to
people building other applications right
now people are either like accessing
that their actual data directly from
those hive tables or they are leveraging
the convict parser and a sort of ad hoc
way
a similar question but kind of at the
other end if I'm an application
developer and I need to make the system
aware of new facts or new dimensions how
does the metrics global metrics
framework become aware of that stuff I'm
not sure I completely understand the
question are you asking about how do new
facts and dimensions get added in so
that they flow through the pipeline
let's say for example like if you build
a new feature and all of a sudden there
becomes like a new entity type like
experiences is like a new feature that
was recently added how does the global
metrics framework become aware so we're
kind of it depends I guess that's sort
of the question so if it's like a whole
new dataset or new metric or new
dimension all that is configurable and
your data scientist or I mean we have
engineers contributing to like whoever
wants to add that entity into the system
can go in and add it if you have say
like a new value flowing in as a
dimension we give you the option of
having data quality checks to make sure
that those dimensions have the expected
values in them so if you have taken that
option you're going to have to go in and
now whitelist that new entity I but
that's flexible for whoever is is
defining that
[Music]